oh [ __ ] man we are here at the scum and
villainy Cantina on Hollywood Boulevard
in Hollywood California the [ __ ]
crotch of Hollywood put your hands
together so the folks at home know
you're real how are you good sir I'm
doing great man yeah me me too I just
handed in a [ __ ] script for this
thing that I've been working on and this
puts us one gigantic step closer to the
moment of truth where they make a
decision and see if we go forward so it
was pretty exciting and I hate like you
know I've been indie since the beginning
right and part of that is nobody ever
was gonna ask me to do stuff but also
part of it was like I just want to do it
my way so I'm in a situation now where
I'm working with others and so you know
you've got to listen to their notes and
[ __ ] and I haven't been there in a while
so like any time people have a note like
my [ __ ] tightens up and [ __ ] because
in my world I'm like when I'm done I'm
done
like that's it and I'll change it when I
want and stuff but like this is it but
when you're working for somebody else
and playing with their toys it's like oh
you're done when we say you're done and
stuff so initially the guy in me that
like doesn't want to [ __ ] change it
the lazy ass in me that's what it comes
down to I'm like I'm feel like I'm
finished can't we just say I'm finished
and move on and show that person has had
I've had to overcome that guy have you
have you deployed the age-old
time-tested we'll take a look at that no
we're gonna give you a note that you're
like [ __ ] like no no we'll take a
look at that you ever take a look at it
III like in fact like they said the crew
I was talking today the development team
the creative folks my execs were just
like because I was talking about I took
you
notes the notes email and I busted it
down into eight screenshots on my phone
that as I was writing I was able to go
through the screenshots and like take
this out and be like I did that and [ __ ]
and they were like I think that's the
most serious anyone has ever taken our
notes and I was like well I mean they
were actually good and that's the thing
that was happiest about it wasn't even
like do these notes because we say - and
I'm like well against better judgment I
will do these notes the notes they gave
actually made it [ __ ] better so like
I turned in the second draft and it took
like a pretty big jump and I really
liked the first draft but I kind of
liked it I guess the long story short is
like trust the process like my I would
jump out of my manager bag when it's
like I change it [ __ ] but then I'm like
do that at home do that on your [ __ ] do
that I'm like what you're working on do
it on Jay and Silent Bob reboot but this
thing working for somebody else like
number one if if it weren't for their
thing you wouldn't be involved in this
project in the first place the only
reason you're there is because some
other thing exists that you got invited
into so I was like m'as weird to switch
over but I found a place where I could
kind of go to and be like oh and also it
helps that the notes were really good so
I know I'm being vague I wish I could
[ __ ] tell you and but the moment I
could tell you man I'm gonna be like wow
how do you be like what the [ __ ] but
it's not a movie I've had a lot of
people be like oh it's a [ __ ] Marvel
book nobody would give me a movie nobody
would give me a movie whatsoever
struggling to make Jay and Silent Bob
reboot this is a serious thing man but
it's a [ __ ] dynamite series at a real
weird wonderful place so more as I know
more how goes Treadstone Treadstone was
going very well we've also had a bunch
of like notes calls within studio in the
network and they seem to be very happy
with things but we're also getting the
notes and it's it's almost never what
they say in the note it's always are
what's the note behind the note why'd
they all keep seem to be bumping on this
particular character bitter this
particular story thing why are they
bumping it's not because of what
actually happens right it's because
something isn't chiming with with them
something isn't squaring their
particular circle right and so it's and
working with new execs it's alright so
what language are they
they're the character people language
the plot people language do they not
like the world do they not like the
person do they not like the moment like
what's what is your actual problem and
I'll never tell you that because if they
could tell you then they would be
writers but it's always Texan next week
marks like I got fired for some reason
[ __ ] happen I just walked in and they
fired me after the podcast dropped why
and those note calls are always like no
it's 15 minutes long or it's an hour and
a half long and the hour and a half ones
you're like oh [ __ ] dude we'll just get
fired no we still got jobs alright I did
one today where you know I was like they
were supposed to have a notes call but
you know it's it's much better being
person they were close enough where it
wasn't like I got a drive to [ __ ]
Santa Monica like [ __ ] that I once had
like it's crazy man like you know now I
mean I was in Jersey kid and [ __ ] but
I've been here we lived in Los Angeles
now 16 years 17 if you count the time
that we made Jay and Silent Bob strike
back and so so I've been out here for a
minute and I know I'm now an Angeleno
because I had somebody fly all the way
out from [ __ ] Canada Eastern Canada
to have a meeting out here in Los
Angeles and they told me like we have to
go to Santa Monica I was like oh I ain't
going to Santa Monica
[ __ ] me that's really far and this guy
was like I came from Ontario I was like
yeah what but you know that's at a
flight like no traffic you got to get on
a [ __ ] freeway have him come to my
house you know so this place they were
really close I was like oh [ __ ] I'll go
do [ __ ] notes it'll take me like 10
minutes to get there ship so when I sat
down and did notes with them today it
was like in in the room and they were
like oh we're a little nervous because
now we're gonna see your face and see
how you react to our notes and I was
like look I'll be honest with you man
like I'll tell you if there's anything I
think you know that I bump into but like
so far this shit's only made it better
like this is how like wonderful the
execs that I've worked with and so I
honestly feel like you know when there's
gonna be a moment when they're like okay
again we're gonna tell you if we're
doing greenlight the series and in this
moment we're gonna tell you this has all
been a series and it's Punk'd and it's
you [ __ ]
like of course you're never gonna work
here you [ __ ] so uh so they were [ __ ]
lovely and like this is how [ __ ]
lovely it was like first draft of the
thing I turned in like you know I got a
bunch of different writing styles you
know I was hidden inside
traditionally I write Kevin Smith stuff
and stuff this kind of thing I was like
alright I'll use the I'll shift to the
other gear and write with that so when I
turned in the draft they were like how
do we say this can you make it more
Kevin Smith and I was like oh yes
[ __ ] but it was really nice they
actually used my work to reference [ __ ]
they were like you know like that scene
in clerks I was like I know all the
scenes and Clark's really well you want
me to recite one for you like familiar
with continued but they were like you
know like that Death Star conversation
like that would be very at home in here
and I'm like oh [ __ ] like I could do
that [ __ ] in my sleep they're like
that's why we hired you so it looks it's
looking pretty good I've enjoyed that
part of the process that was a part of
the process I always felt like that's
where it'll fall apart the wheels will
fall off like I don't work well with
others and that's not true I worked very
well with others when it's my thing but
like when it's other people's things
then it's been a while since I've done
that and I don't know how to play but so
far so good
in the last episode we talked about
possibly coming up with a new name for
the show and a bunch of people but very
nice suggestions up online and stuff and
and there's a few that we've been like
thinking about in circles mark and I
came up with a short list of the names
we've liked it yeah so far some came
from the public some came from just
internally and stuff like that but we're
collecting them but just to give a
shout-out to the to those who have the
public the one that we're like oh that
you know that the public suggested the
leading suggestion and there's been a
few people that that did it so apologies
to whoever did it first but there have
been a bunch of them and stuff maybe
calling it you know instead of calling
it fat man on Batman which is twofold
like chiefly in my mind sooner or later
Warner Brothers gonna be like you can't
call things Batman any ever again you
don't own that [ __ ] character and
[ __ ] and then also a lot of people
online are like you can't call
man that's false advertising and [ __ ] so
we had to look for to think about
looking for a new name and so the one
online that I think is adorable and [ __ ]
and fits with the podcast is fat man
beyond right that's pretty good pretty
[ __ ] magical man so so will as if as
we get closer if it happens man just
that seems to be the leading continue
like well we'll find some milestone yeah
it'll be like all right episode 250 fat
man beyond that and then beyond moving
on it's kind of sweet man I do like it
and then like we can get a trilogy going
somewhere like 80 years old it'll be fat
man forever and [ __ ] when we get
replacement hosts this fat man begins
yes oh my god okay so that's a [ __ ] the
opening now we gotta get to the meat of
the show man there are two parts to the
show well 3 in the beginning we sit
around chitchat but then we come to the
part of the show which is my favorite
cuz this is where I get to catch up on a
lot of [ __ ] my head has been buried in a
script all week so I have not been
paying attention to pop culture my
finger has been off the pulse mark on
the other hand has aggregated all the
news by going to the internet and
stealing it from others I have indeed to
bring it here to you so we could discuss
and give it up for Mark he's got the
news yes Mike my finger is now has been
on the pulse for like half an hour how
many stories are a bunch of news we are
like 5 new stories I think I know one
all right which one do you think you
know uh the one about Batman's dad yes a
big [ __ ] story
that's the leading story is lead lead
away it's great story uh do you guys
know they're making another Joker movie
I think we know they're making 18 Joker
movies which one is this this is the
todd phillips joaquin phoenix joker
movie the one that's imminent yes and
they just cast Martha Wayne's husband
also known as known as Thomas Wayne also
known as honest
aka Batman's dad yes uh Alec Baldwin is
going to play Thomas Wayne what I I like
this idea very much when I first saw the
headline on Twitter the only thing that
would have made this better for me was I
thought it said Alec Baldwin cast as
Batman and I was like holy [ __ ] they're
going for it man like old Batman and
[ __ ] would be kind of bad it would be
cool but for those of us that remember
when Tim Burton was gearing up like with
his first historic Batman Alec Baldwin
was one of the leading contenders like
and if you were gonna pick somebody from
the cast of beetlejuice
it was probably it was probably gonna be
Alec Baldwin he looked the part and [ __ ]
like that but then Tim Burton went left
and it was Michael Keaton who was
absolutely brilliant and then years
later Alec Baldwin got a got to kind of
play a Batman as Batman ish character
with the shadow yeah where there's only
two years later she's like after is that
right no no I was like 93 so yeah about
maybe four years later but it was so
weird cuz they did a makeup job on they
didn't just put a scarf on him as Lamont
Cranston and he became the shadow the
makeup job they did on him made him look
like Billy Baldwin it was really weird
go watch that movie and you'll be like
Alec Baldwin Billy Baldwin we have the
most handsome man in Hollywood what
should we do with his face cuz no [ __ ]
it up for a while so he never got to do
it and it's kind of sweet that you know
he's gonna wind up in some way touching
the Batman mythos I think it's cool I
know some people like have issues with
him and stuff but I like him I think
it's a good casting call I would just
like for her from Glengarry Glen Ross
who gave one of the greatest monologues
in cinema history it's like that gets
you for my money a pass for the rest of
your life like go being anything you
want [ __ ] even what was it [ __ ]
business baby or whatever [ __ ] it was
called what was it boss be boss baby
yeah yeah he gets a pass like English
baby it's like way more interesting
business baby
your thoughts on Alec Baldwin enough I
am sort of darkly wishing that this is a
bit of a cover story in there making
Dark Knight Returns yeah and they're
just not gonna tell us that for was like
we're making another Joker movie
nobody's gonna pay attention because
nobody's wants it but now he's [ __ ]
playing Bruce Wayne he's playing he's
not but I want it to be I wish they
would have held him for like flashpoint
and let him play old Thomas Wayne and
maybe they can do that right like he's
like just because he's Thomas Wayne and
this don't mean he can't be Thomas Wayne
and that as well
yeah because him as that Batman from
from flashpoint would be pretty amazing
yeah but that's good news all around
this cast is shaping up who else is in
this movie let's see Joaquin Phoenix is
playing Joe Phoenix De Niro Francis
Conroy De Niro is playing a comic or TV
host or something I said Zizi beats we
don't know who she's playing she was
Domino - it was amazing
we don't know she's playing them and
Marc Maron Marc Maron we don't know he's
playing either no I'm hoping he says we
have to buy a fence anybody want to buy
a gate almost famous lock the gates lock
the gates he's the guy that says the
gate lock the gates
that's Marc Maron Marc Maron really and
you can tell because it's in the intro
to every [ __ ] episode of his podcast
which there's a little some [ __ ]
music montage and then the aneurysm lock
the gates
oh look at you back to her Maron fan and
I am very much a backdrop front door man
fan time whatever door he wants baby no
doubt okay I the version of Thomas Wayne
they said he's playing though that seems
noteworthy what version is it what did
you ain't 1980s I've seen it referred to
his almost trumpian character mm-hmm
like a version of Thomas Wayne we
haven't seen before they I've seen the
word sleazy and 80s used alright that's
a good choice yeah I mean there's the
thing he's always been portrayed like
who was it Linus Roache
in Batman Begins as like this noble soul
noble doctor and stuff so I don't know
what this Thomas Wayne is gonna be like
but I did see those two just script
yeah I mean that's I I guess the because
Batman Bruce Wayne needs to be informed
by his relation to Thomas Wayne yes
because that kid does not become Batman
unless he's got a dad who either teaches
him to be a better person to you know
sort of change course of the way why do
we fall down totally inspirational
figure or he's gonna be the shitty dad
that Bruce Wayne rebels against and if
you're gonna make him Donald Trump and
he wants to be nothing like his [ __ ]
dad he then goes off and becomes an
urban superhero true I guess I see that
but that's that's if you're making a
Batman movie this is a joker movie but
then I certainly agree then don't
understand why Thomas Wayne is here if
Bruce Wayne in some fashion doesn't play
a part so does that mean that this story
takes place before Batman and the Joker
meet with Thomas Wayne still around is
Bruce Wayne young he must be you know
because if Thomas Wayne hasn't died
maybe it's a story in some alternate
universe where you know Batman didn't
happen yet or Bruce Wayne didn't come
Batman because if Thomas Waynes around
how do you tell that story
maybe his flashpoint that's like when
you were like oh I wish they were doing
something I'm not telling us that's the
first thing I thought it was like
imagine if they were making a back door
where I'm using that phrase a lot
tonight they were secretly making
flashpoint but what would be the benefit
of secretly doing it you know post the
flash movie which is apparently supposed
to be flashpoint so if it is going to
mean in universe thing but they've said
it's this stands apart this is the one
that's like they could also be lying oh
good point fair enough I mean Star Wars
has blue harvest for a while yes yeah I
guess there could be a bat a baton
switch if you will thank you wordplay
trying to keep it on brand okay so
that's that one story that's that one
story then what happened
there's a couple of cast additions to
episode 9 Oh JJ new Star Wars pick a new
Star Wars picture okay
Dominic Monaghan from lost oh wow yeah
yeah JJ wants him back and so he's being
pressed into oh that's the connection
that would mask
so he's gonna be a Matt Smith Doctor Who
and the crown is joining in an
unspecified role none of these roles are
specified aside from the ones who've
already seen before but if if I had to
guess I would say he will have something
to do with Rey something to do maybe not
parentage maybe sibling maybe something
I don't know but [ __ ] dark-haired
Britt and one other dark-haired Britt
the way that he seems to work that's
true they're all kind of related a
friend of mine Brian who does comedy
dynamics that's this company I did the
stand-up special with him he also does a
show which I [ __ ] love called toys
that made us on Netflix documentary
series gorgeous so I [ __ ] love that
show and you know first time I watched I
was tweeting it up blown sucking its
dick like wow I [ __ ] love this the
only thing I didn't love about it was
like why aren't I on this [ __ ] thing
so I told them that and they put me on
next season so they interviewed me for
something and [ __ ] and so as if we were
interviewing we were bullshitting about
[ __ ] star wars and stuff and he came
up he he [ __ ] hit me with something
knocked my [ __ ] socks off it's a
theory right he ain't even connected to
the Star Wars world and [ __ ] but man it
was [ __ ] strong so we were talking
about Clone Wars coming back and my I
said to him I got a theory that you know
that's the way to inch start introducing
ahsoka slowly into the live-action
movies by bringing her back prominently
in the cartoon because now that they
don't have Princess Leia stories to tell
they need another strong female
character in the universe and ahsoka has
been there for years and much-beloved
just isn't in the movie so I was like I
think maybe they're doing that so they
can slowly bring her in to the movies
and then Brian blows my [ __ ] mind by
going maybe to ask who carry Russell's
playing and then I said what the [ __ ]
man
I want to see your version of Star Wars
and then I started fighting them because
I was like now that can't be it I think
Keri Russell probably playing like Ray's
mom and then he [ __ ] drops the bomb
he goes what if it's the same person so
instantly I wrote to JJ Abrams you must
do this
could you imagine that be [ __ ] wild I
don't think it is but that was one of
the greatest fan theories that's right
wouldn't that be so [ __ ] hot with her
like not only as I soak in these movies
but she's [ __ ] Ray's mom
holy [ __ ] and somewhere Ryan Johnson's
like what the [ __ ] you know I know yeah
I said they were trash Jedi trash did i
total trash what arts is that the only
cast that they've added yeah that and
I'm Matt Smith movie's gonna be huge
that's the understatement of the year
yeah I mean people will come see it do
you think though will solo sort of
workshop that a little bit more we saw
you know Solo wasn't like widely
embraced and stuff do you think there's
anything - a lot of online theories of
like a man the fanbase is mad and
they're punishing Star Wars I feel even
if that was the case everybody loves
force awakens don't think I mean like
they still do I think and I imagine JJ
they'll welcome him back and he's what
I'm thinking my we talked about it at
some point they went solo came up and I
think there's just a little bit of
fatigue in that these movies are all
driven by nostalgia
they're all driven by our desire to feel
the way we felt the first time I ever
saw Star Wars you know you're saying
we're already nostalgic for [ __ ] JJ's
force awakens this is like it only
happened a minute ago
[ __ ] it was good but I think it helps to
not have won another one this year
a little help to go another year and a
half before we get on the Star Wars
movie so it's not every six months right
it's hard to be nostalgic for it then
you get all the time
and so if you build in some distance if
you allow yourself to stoke that desire
then yeah all right unlike more
which is [ __ ] TV show and you better
give me an episode every six months
otherwise I'm gonna forget what happened
in your TV show my new go-to movie to
watch like when I'm done with [ __ ] and
I've got a little window of time like me
time or if I'm sitting there smoking in
the morning [ __ ] is infinity war
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is so so good it's it may
be one of the most watchable right up
there for me with the first iron man I
think is an eminently watchable movie
once it ends I get started again like I
could go on that adventure it's perfect
like motion picture experience this I
feel the same way about this is much
longer it's meteor and stuff so you have
sections that you like that you [ __ ]
go to like I'm gonna go from right after
spoilers Gamora goes away forward cuz
that's where [ __ ] gets [ __ ] nuts
where sometimes I'm like I just want to
see Tony Stark be shitty to Doctor
Strange like I just two dudes and
goatees being jerks to each other
like oh I [ __ ] love it it's so
goddamn dynamite man it's have you been
why have you watched it since I'm Devin
yet I have it at home and I've been
watching it you know it's [ __ ] fun to
do you could go to the end of Thor
Ragnarok and watch their PS scene and
then start infinity war whoo it's and
it's because there's like a kind of like
sense of humor to the Thor version of it
[ __ ] and then you enter into Infinity
Ward and suddenly it's like [ __ ] goes
dark right away but it's a fun thing to
do I feel there's a dude over there who
hasn't seen it yet and yeah that guy so
I saw like [ __ ] tears coming out his
eyes like I've been just waiting like I
was gonna finish my residency and it was
my one reward for doing the [ __ ]
thing and now you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
I meant I meant to lead with spoilers
but I I assumed we'd all seen it yeah
man it's [ __ ] good I look forward to
like a man and wasp and on home video so
I can like start drilling that over and
over again but right now infinity war is
so [ __ ] satisfying like that you can
I've gone I've gone
- it every morning I've woken up where
I'm like I'm gonna kick back and watch a
bunch of this [ __ ] and stuff I'm so
[ __ ] good do you know how [ __ ]
close they came in as you know it's off
topic but on topic they came so close to
getting the [ __ ] glove off of man
like it's so irritating so [ __ ]
irritating like it was off his [ __ ]
hand and then that when his I [ __ ]
wakes up and he [ __ ] grabs it back
you're like you [ __ ] idiot star-lord
like and I know it like this all has to
happen so there could be another movie
and [ __ ] but like I get so frustrated
and you understand that's what it's such
good writing man like we had those
[ __ ] sitting right here like
that you buy it you buy the fact that
star-lord would [ __ ] do that you
don't buy that I mean I I buy it it's
Peter Peter quill he's that [ __ ]
stupid like you know look we're like
they were that close and that's all
because he's like this is my plan and
then he [ __ ] up his own plan and yeah
yeah I buy him being that [ __ ] stupid
I'm being good and he's never bought it
we talked about it when we talked about
the movies yeah I just I don't buy the
relationship with Gamora to the extent
that he's so heartbroken over her death
that he is willing to risk the world
that part i buy especially because like
they gave us a set up scene with like
you know where they were a little more
tender than we'd ever seen them be
before i guess man but I suppose there's
a girl I can meet on a spaceship and
smooch a couple times but I wouldn't
risk the entire [ __ ] cosmos sorry
half the cosmos somewhere Mark's wife is
rolling a tears
not even for me from needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few or the one
not for me man I I got somebody that I
got a wife who is [ __ ] fan us and she
snapped half my world disappeared man
that was that [ __ ] so and then she sat
peacefully on the porch for the rest of
the [ __ ]
all right what else we got
speaking of marvel yeah always speak of
mark always speak a mother
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 yeah this
was kind of a bummer uh has been shut
down yeah not like killed not killed but
they were ramping up they were staffing
a pre pre pre productive heads who were
getting start to work they were gonna
start location scouting because there's
a script that's written that I think
they're still going to use or are they I
would like to see the end of history
because it wasn't like to didn't feel
like the middle you know what I'm saying
it didn't feel like oh there's something
[ __ ] you know this is just a holding
pattern until we get to three I thought
it was a very satisfying story in and of
itself but clearly he had a he had more
and a story that was gonna link all
three right you think it would like just
calling it out from do you see any loose
threads that he had to tie yeah like we
found out who Peters dad was in the
second movie Adam [ __ ] warlock that's
right man oh my god that was at the end
of the [ __ ] movie Adam Worrell and
you've got a fold Captain Marvel into it
because she's got to be a part of the
whole cosmic [ __ ] anyway were they gonna
do that in guardians of the galaxy I
don't know but it wouldn't surprise me
if they did she's coming soon her own
flick right like is that the next movie
yeah
when is that May it's the next one we
haven't seen a trailer
yeah no interesting what's Disney's big
November Christmas movie where they have
because that's what it would be on so
you don't think we'll see anything
when's d23 or whatever when's their
convention next year they're not doing
it so when do you think they'll drop
Captain Marvel trailer September like so
this meaning this month yeah it wouldn't
surprise get us something to look
forward to man like holy [ __ ] I was just
reading through September gone what a
[ __ ] month now my [ __ ] name and every
morning I'll wake up look at my phone
and [ __ ] are these two minutes here yet
no okay these two minutes that'll make
me get through the next eight months
[Laughter]
yeah maybe they'll do it on whatever
giant ABC show they want to launch in
the fall they do the like stay tuned for
a sneak peak of Captain Marvel it's
awake Captain Marvel happens when I
think it's May no isn't that when that's
when infinity war happens word Avengers
for so do you think Captain Marvel's
have to watch the end of this year
captain worlds not this year it's next
year but so it has to happen in 2019
but before may yes so somewhere marchers
March 8th so thank you finally listed
the Internet
well done man thank you we're all
sitting here going I wonder what it
could be could be a hippo
yes all right so that's something that
[ __ ] look for it's kind of amazing
like when I was a journalist when I was
a young journalist I used to have all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] just memorized like I
had to know whatever release date was
because I'm planning coverage for six
months out now that I don't I don't know
what's happening next week oh [ __ ] no I
bet you there's movies what are they
there's all right so so yes so they were
released most of those department heads
and Guardians vol 3 yeah it had never
had a date so it's not like they're
shifting on the schedule they just never
put her on the schedule for real and
they're starting to talk to directors
about who possibly could maybe do it the
room well does that a rumor
take away whitey he had a meeting I mean
Marvel that to me would make the most
sense in a world where they have to
replace and like that you know they're
not making a new Thor movie right away
so it's not like hey he's got he's
writing to the next Thor flick right
like it feels like you can shift him
over to the garden sensibility was in
the same Venn diagram right funny and
stuff but you know and also that might
salve the wound a little bit right
because everyone loved for Ragnarok and
everybody seems to dig him so at least
they're not like you know ladies and
gentlemen you know my god babe raaaah
[Laughter]
they're like weeds in which it's gonna
work this time
take it away around our wood we get to
do this kind of edgy space drama comedy
science fiction thing
should we team him up with another
director now let Ron do it solo oh you
are never to say those words together in
the same sentence again it's a good
movie man what's that movie come on home
video oh I look forward to watching that
that's scene with Chuy when he meets
Chuy I've been thinking about a lot like
it's a well done scene but sure that'll
be a fun home watch moving over again
you might be able to find it on the
internet already is it out there I mean
I bet you'd like everything is out there
if you really want it that's true are
you trying to send me to the dark web
for this movie he's like you can [ __ ]
order a hit and watch so long
stay on the path don't stray from the
path all right so that's gonna be a
bummer man that means we're waiting
longer for a Guardians movie it's not a
they never picked a date yet anyway
right it wasn't scheduled it wasn't
scheduled but but now it's permanently
not scheduled correct
until they figure [ __ ] out you know that
they're gonna do it it's not like
they're like well we've given up on
guardians but they're just gonna take a
breath your momentum towards making a
movie is now stopped and so they'll find
a guy and then they'll start up the
[ __ ] machine again oh my god whatever
will Marvel do without that one movie
you know what I'm saying I got like
twenty six going you know if you don't
like that one stick around there's
another one [ __ ] so I look
forward to whatever they decide but yeah
I want us I want more with those
characters of course and and to be fair
infinity war was kind of like guardians
of the galaxy 2.5 the way that like Iron
Man 3 was kind of Avengers 1.5 liked it
kind of mini sequel of sorts and stuff
so that will hold for a little while I
think so and I think I mean at some
point we're gonna get a black panther -
well that's if he survives theosis I
mean looking snap mark
I don't I see you seem very confident
but he king of Wakanda disappeared right
in front of us he really did as did all
the future billions of dollars at the
box office that they could make with
that character we don't want that yeah
Disney's like you sure you don't want to
make another one Kevin bug he's like no
we killed him he's dead he's gone he's
gone that's how it happens in comics
they die and never come back
death is permanent all right what's the
next door did you ever as a child and/or
adult read Isaac Asimov's foundation
never know they do no what is it about
did you I tried it's uh it's it's it's
fascinating but dense basically what is
it about it's charting the history of a
Galactic Empire Oh through the eyes of
one character who sort of seems to be
like the computer programmer who
predicted how the [ __ ] galaxy unfolds
am i [ __ ] this up entirely or I'm
sure I am whether there is some science
what's the name of the science like
psycho metrics or some [ __ ] so did I
get that right holy [ __ ] I got
psychohistory ah we were both wrong you
really selling the [ __ ] out of this man
it is it is one of science fiction's pun
totally intended foundational texts that
uh that I also cannot get through but
Apple gave it a director series order
because Apple is now making television
they are man that nobody has seen any of
yet yeah they have just they're handing
out orders to everybody in their grandma
there there's a lot of people that got
deals over at Apple right now and they
they I guess they'll be announcing their
channel within the next year right if
it's even going to be a channel and not
just an app on your phone and that's how
you watch everything true or something
that already like exists like they have
a video watching platform now that's
actually pretty good
do they so it could just be that right
they could just be like and now here's a
channel or something could be so wait
who's doing that show who's in charge
David Goyer of the Man of Steel's
the dark nights yeah and the blades yeah
and Josh Friedman who was the executive
or creator of Terminator Sarah Connor
Chronicles okay who wrote war the
world's for Spielberg I like that one or
eight of the nine or 12 avatar sequels
that they're making really yeah because
they seem to be adding them as they go
no doubt like every six months they're
trying to beat [ __ ] Warner Brothers
at Joker movies the look you could have
more yes remember Avatar I'm not sure
let's make five more yeah yeah he is
gone he's [ __ ] invest in deep and
blue cats isn't he I mean I mean I know
it worked the one time right like
[ __ ] he made all the money and she
became king of the world
again like I don't know if I'm sure I'm
sure he knows what he's doing but does
the world's kind of move down from blue
cats no I don't I'm curious enough
anybody in this room could name the main
character a [ __ ] avatar Jake Sully
Wow I'm uh I just remembered cuz what's
your name no that line is Zoey Gamora
come over remembers who Jake Sully yeah
but I also would defy you to find me
like a 12 year old kid who knows who the
[ __ ] anybody is in that movie yeah and
so alright remember who's in it
and all those blue kittens in space do I
need four more of those or they maybe
they win just because people like hey
it's not a comic book movie for a change
or something like that
I mean I'm again it made 2.8 billion
dollars I'm sayin somebody [ __ ] likes
these cats like you know it's not like
he's gonna put a second one out there
and nobody shows up somebody's gonna
[ __ ] show up but like it has been a
minute that's now in forever I guess
true it's I bet he relishes the
challenge too because no matter what he
does right there's always somebody going
on I don't know Jim you know I don't
know if this boat hitting the iceberg is
gonna work and you all know how it ends
I don't know Jim blue cats in space so
he seems to thrive well when people
doubt him so maybe maybe avatar
2 through 12 will be you know [ __ ]
something magnificent I'm in I like the
first one so much so that I memorized
the main character's name but I couldn't
tell you the name of the the lady cat
what was her name
materi oh look at you you're a deep fan
- no I'm just not curious anybody else
knows some [ __ ] about some [ __ ] either
yeah I'll tell you - people are gonna be
there when the sequel's open us
apparently mr. Kaveri
don't miss the camera we have to go
cosplay I'll be jakesully and you be
[Applause]
material a cab you like him like no jig
silly I don't see color man see they're
making foundation yeah which you're very
nice about yeah but the world seems to
kind of wonder if you're and said that
dudes head Wow they shouldn't make it so
what you're saying is Apple is making
the worst decision in the world like hey
what if we took away your headphone plug
and made you plug everything into that
one [ __ ] tortilla
we're brilliant why would you not want
to just have one hole on your phone I'm
not even I was gonna go down the rabbit
hole of one hole but I'm [ __ ] backdoor
from my goddamn headphones no yeah these
guys are brilliant you resent that you
look I don't want to pee and poo from
the same hole god damn it see they're
making that show yeah one last story one
final story okay why don't light
Newsweek yeah knowing knowing your love
and perhaps rediscovered love given your
Instagram feed of Disneyland yes there
was an auction in in Sherman Oaks
yeah they had an exhibit like a pop-up
pop-up exhibit slash auction where my
cousin went to it Emily she [ __ ]
loved it she's Disney kids so she was
absolutely in love with it some guy had
a private collection yeah of a bunch of
[ __ ] that he'd collected from
Disneyland over the years maybe you
could I don't know how I got it you
can't like go to Disneyland and be like
hey man can i buy some [ __ ] he's he's an
agent name is Richard crafts I don't
know what agency works for ok but over
the past 25 years he's been collecting
this insanely auction of Disney [ __ ] and
so we held an auction and raised
record-setting
8.3 million dollars worth of Disney
shitty sold including can I have some
figures go tell me uh let's see an
original Skyway vehicle which sold for
621 thousand dollars what do you mean
asked I bucket yeah from back in the day
wow that's old man how much 621 jeez a
dumb more importantly than what they
paid can you tell us who bought these
things because I want to hit him up and
be like look you want to invest in a
motion picture there's a lot more
reliable than a Scott bucket I'll tell
you that I will give you the whole ride
yeah I know that's just broke that's why
I got rid of it right a Dumbo attraction
vehicle which sold for four hundred
eighty three thousand dollars see that's
[ __ ] crazy to me I would imagine
Dumbo would be six hundred thousand a
sky bucket would be under that but like
wow man you'd like how [ __ ] difficult
would it be to lay hands on a Dumbo
let's see what else we got an original
Haunted Mansion portrait for four
hundred two thousand Haunted Mansion
doom buggy for two hundred twenty
thousand one of the doom buggies went
for two hundred how much into the mic no
two hundred twenty wow man that would be
something worth Evan and David
Copperfield bought one of the the neon
letter D from the Disneyland Hotel 486
G's David Copperfield buddy buddy
why did he just come in and be like it's
gone I knew that [ __ ] wasn't real wow
man that I've stink I wonder if it's
that deed that I used to see like when
he traveled my Holland like somebody had
a big D I wonder if it's that huge I
wonder if it's that man he had ever felt
a particular set of balls that is yeah
man eight million dollars [ __ ] nuts I
think they had a mr. toad car as well
one of the cars from mr. toad which I
you know when I first heard about it I
was like oh I'll check it out and then
when I started hearing how much things
were selling for I was like oh I'm not
doing that nope
I don't have that kind of crazy money is
there anything that you would like to
buy or own like my friend Dave Mandel
has an original stormtrooper helmet from
Star Wars from a new hope and stuff and
I remember this going way the [ __ ] back
when we were working on the clerks
cartoon so in the [ __ ] 90s like 98 99
he had paid like 20 grand for it and I
was like that's [ __ ] crazy expensive
and now it's worth way [ __ ] more
men's because there's a whole business
around the [ __ ] is there anything that
you would like I pay cash money to own
that if you had if I had the money if
you had disposed if I had dumb [ __ ]
money yeah I would and that's not let's
not make a dumb money where you're like
I'm a billionaire so you know I own a
yacht like I'm doing alright
you're doing alright but there's enough
extra scratch where you're like I
deserve this or like it would hurt a
little but not like I got to sell the
house right okay I would I would buy the
fertility God from rate as the law star
that you could do that and you wouldn't
be destroyed I bet you that wouldn't be
that much I don't know why that Raiders
is one of them I mean I love fertility
but Raiders is what I'm
I hate [ __ ] and nothing happens
what's the [ __ ] point but I love that
movie I love that scene that that
sequence is what movies are right
ultimately look it's that end it's the
trench run like that those two things
define for me what cinema can do hmm
with nothing but just [ __ ] light and
magic just I can make you feel I can
make you tense I can make you cheer I
had a moment like that yesterday
tomorrow I'm doing this live stream
online obviously
for the for the DC you know DC Universe
the app we forgot to talk about this yes
I get to host and introduce like DC
daily as the show that they're gonna
have on the app every day and stuff and
so we shot from the well we shot promos
from the set we did a rehearsal because
it's like a 90-minute live program and
stuff lots of guests and we kind of show
off the DC show off the DC Universe and
women so on stage on the set they had
you know there's a Batman pinball
machine there's the bat missile from
Batman Returns when the sides blew off
the car got then they've got one of the
Superman costumes and they had the
Batman costume from 1989 Batman the very
first one they went there like we went
into the archives pulled it out we had
to do some refurbishment if you look
close it's aged a bit because they shot
that movie back in 88 89 it's tough but
there it was the same [ __ ] Batman
costume that like you know for those who
were alive then we'll remember it well
like 1989 defined bat mania like it was
[ __ ] people were cutting the bat
symbol into their hair and [ __ ] you
could not [ __ ] avoid it like I don't
think there's been that much enthusiasm
or excitement for an unseen movie like
it for my money since then it was just
[ __ ] huge and stuff and I was a part
of that I couldn't wait man I was
reading comics at that point I was like
they're making the real Batman this time
not that [ __ ] out of wish
it which years later I would apologize
to Adam West personally for sale and he
would feel like that's okay Kevin I'm
not the Dark Knight I'm the Bright
Knight you know sweet lovely man so I
got to see that costume up close and
personal refurbished and then there it
is
including remember the back cymbal
design was slightly different and had
little edges at the bottom of it [ __ ]
it's crazy dude he's literally wearing a
pair of Nikes like the Batman shoes our
a pair of painted up [ __ ] Nikes it's
not like we created a brand new shoe
they were like paint up some Nikes it'll
be fine the outfit itself that's where
Anton first drew the line it was like
[ __ ] this yeah he's like they can
they'll settle for this the costume
itself is you know it's the sculpted
that was the way they introduced the
idea of like here's a costume that'll
make you look like you're muscular and
[ __ ] and they gave him the ripped
[ __ ] stomach when you touch it it's
made of the same material that the
fleshlight is made of so I was like I
want this that all being said watch the
livestream tomorrow as we explore DC
Universe is that why Michael Keaton
couldn't turn his head crazy I'm just
one big [ __ ] erect penis and I just
can't it's this he's this Batman it's so
[ __ ] crazy when you look at it up
close though like nobody there they just
couldn't solve that issue like they'd
even try to solve that issue until Chris
Nolan was like let's just put a
motorcycle helmet on him and [ __ ] then
he could turn his head but up until then
man it's one sculpted piece so when he
put on the cowl he was putting on the
Cape as well like it was all one piece
so you had to turn like this cuz you
imagine the [ __ ] like it the Batman
in the comics is like one of the
greatest fighters that your universe has
ever produced
the Batman in those movies had to be an
even better fighter because all I could
do was this [ __ ]
listen you guys just single file behind
them if we just hide this blind spot I
think is it can you step over here so I
could punch you do you see Michael
Keaton is a few months back but he gave
like graduation speech to one of the
colleges at the end of the speech he's
like and I if I can leave you with two
words of wisdom it's this I'm Batman and
then he walked away it's so [ __ ]
awesome all right no more news no more
news how's the end of the news give it
up for Markie took us off for the news
[Applause]
that means that we've come to the part
of the show the other part of the show
that I absolutely love and the audience
seems to they'd like it as much as well
usually online I see a lot of nice
reaction to this part of the show this
is where we dive into Q&A ladies and
gentlemen the Q&A here at fat man on
Batman at scum and villainy here in
Hollywood does it's not just you ask a
question you get an answer and that's
your prize if you ask a question and
your questions good then you're gonna
win something you're gonna win a pair of
tickets to 40x experience man as you
watch a movie in 40x you've never seen a
movie in 40x
oh my god you've not seen a [ __ ]
movie you are having only a quarter of
the movie going experience what is your
problem if you haven't gone to a 40x
theater it's an awesome [ __ ] way to
watch movie if it snows in the movie it
snows in the [ __ ] theater if
something explodes
it smells like [ __ ] something
exploded in the theater it's really cool
man and they got one it's like going
outside for people hate going outside
yes yes 4dx has done an amazing job of
recreating a world you don't want to
interact right there and in the heart of
the movie theater and there at LA Live
that's where you can go see it
our good friend Deacon Brett Deacon God
gives us those tickets every week give
it up for Brett Deacon ladies John he's
not here but still
alright so we got five sets of tickets
two tickets each man and thanks to the
sweet heart of cat ears over there Jamie
you these two of them are yours these
are not yours right those are somebody
else's so Jamie for some reason wound up
with a number of Kevin Smith pops and
she's like yeah so she's she's offered
to give them out as part of the prize
pack man so if your question is super
[ __ ] good not only you're gonna win
40 X tickets you're gonna win a pop on
top of it but if you pop on top but if
you up on top it rhymes
but if you if you don't win the pop on
top of it you're still winning tickets
and [ __ ] so don't walk away going oh my
[ __ ] wasn't good enough
did these not fit in the in the box
spring of pop figures you had built at
home of Kevin Smith why are you giving
these away are they I don't collect them
and I have a ton of them that people
keep thinking I want I have the same
problem people are always giving me the
Kevin Smith pop oh my god wanted oh
right on
no I'm very sweet give it up for Jamy
man she's uh she threw some [ __ ] out she
didn't want and now you guys are gonna
benefit from it
okay JC's got a microphone JC we let him
pick he's the proprietor of this here
bar we always let him pick man and he's
picked first butcher named Captain Neil
Neil give it up for Neil everybody's hey
oh you know you know what the deal what
can we do you for man hey first off I
want to have a quick shout out to my
buddy got Jason in North Carolina who
got me into your films way back in the
day and I became a huge fan of easly and
I wouldn't be here tonight if it wasn't
for Jason so thank you Jason that's
[ __ ] awesome give it up for Jason man
looking out for his boy somewhere Jason
right now is Washington home rolling a
[ __ ] tear and what's creepy and you
don't know this is he's jerking off at
the same time
you will be hey I also want to thank you
about a month ago I was down here and
you were running a bit late and you said
sorry I was stuck in traffic because
Tarantino is shooting down this way when
we did the show so after the podcast
raft
I walked down there and the sidewalk on
this side of Hollywood Boulevard was
wide open to pedestrians so you could
walk from one side of the set to the
other and he had a totally pimped out in
1969 style for those who you don't know
it's the the Charles Manson movie set
back in 6 was it once upon a time in
Hollywood exactly yeah so you can walk
from one end of the set to the other
cherri vintage cars all the storefronts
were totally retro he had like the old
pussycat porno theater set up a peaches
record story was it was so cool look
like they spent a few bucks yeah
absolutely but it was when the songs the
bums flavor they just threw bell-bottoms
on him I had him walk around his ass
they gave him new clothes exactly but I
wouldn't have seen that we're gonna need
those clothes back I wouldn't have seen
that if you hadn't told me about so
thanks man alright so much nice to get
an update on that story yeah so my
question is gonna be a Tarantino
question fair enough so I'm quitting
Tarantino and I come to you guys and I
say mark Kevin after I get done with
this once upon a time in the Hollywood
movie I'm gonna do a comic book film
adaptation right I want to keep it kind
of mainstream Marvel of DC and it's
gonna have all the hallmarks of a
Tarantino movie I'm gonna write it I'm
gonna direct it you know multiple
nonlinear intersecting storylines harsh
language graphic violence all that and
since I'm Quentin Tarantino there's only
like eight guys in this [ __ ] town
that I like to cast right so Sam Jackson
Michael Madsen Christoph Waltz Tim Roth
uma Thurman we all know who they are so
I'm going to make a violent r-rated
comic book adaptation with using my guys
as the protagonist and antagonist and
I'm gonna ask you guys who I should use
because no one's more dialed into this
[ __ ] than you - badass talented
[ __ ] so whatever you tell me
whatever you tell me to do I'm gonna do
so tell me I would say first off Quentin
that's the most you've ever said to me
in my entire life
[Applause]
am i dying why are we having this
conversation let me see
Quentin's looking for advice for what
hey what should I do in the column yeah
what title should I adapt I want to cast
it using you know my hallmark actors I
like to work with can I do I'll do Delta
2 I'll do a Marvel and a DC cool nice
for Marvel master of kungfu there's a
Marvel Comics character called master of
Kung Fu which like I know he also wants
to do like I remember when I was
shooting that same movie I talked about
before catch and release when you're an
actor in a movie you've got a lot of
pretty [ __ ] time and one day I was in
my trailer I had enough time to watch
both Kill Bill volume 1 and volume 2 and
so I'm Lia most people when they like
something they go to the internet they
like I [ __ ] like this so much but
because my job I was like I'm just gonna
[ __ ] call him and suck his dick on
the phone man because like I just really
enjoyed the experience and all I go on
to share was somebody I was I got
[ __ ] share it with him so I called
him up and I was like oh my god dude I
just watched [ __ ] both both movies
back to back again it's like [ __ ]
like two is one of my favorite movies of
all time his beautiful [ __ ] family
drama hidden what's inside like you know
kung fu movie and [ __ ] like that is the
story of a broken heart it's story about
a relationship of marriage gone awry and
stuff you know just dressed up in many
different ways so I was talking about
that and then I was talking about the
first one of course is [ __ ] you know
martial arts crazy and I said is
fantastic man it's just lovely and he
goes well I'm gonna I know I want to do
it one more time I said why and he goes
because just when I learned how to make
a chop-socky movie we were done like it
was finished I've made Kill Bill Vol
wanted to and suddenly was finished so
I've got all these skills I know how to
do it in my sleep so I know I got to
make one more before I leave this world
and [ __ ] so knowing I've had that
conversation with him I would tell her
master of kung foo would be right up his
[ __ ] alley and stuff and it involves
fu-manchu's a character and stuff he
would do it [ __ ] justice for the DC
side there was a Garth
aniss book is it car yes called hitman
Tommy Monahan like the kind of darker
side of the DC Universe and stuff he
would he would make that into something
absolutely wonderful and granted I've
picked to like not the Sexy's like
[ __ ] you know spider-man or something
like that
but those are two that I think he would
absolutely destroy and elevate at the
same time yeah and you think Michael
Matsuda work for the hit man I think he
would but I think he'd probably cast
Brad Pitt as the hit man and [ __ ] like
that seems to be Quentin's go to movies
like Brad Pitt what about you
III think I go similar for Marvel okay I
think I go daughters of the Dragon nice
I think and you could even period that
up you can even make that 70s if you
want to so Colleen winged misty night so
I've been detectives New York like
underbelly kung-fu you still get all
that [ __ ] in there yes but I think I
think you're right I think he digs into
that [ __ ] for real yeah um DC I
transmitter Politan is my poll if you've
never read Warren Alice's trans
metropolitan it is this deep [ __ ]
science fiction satire about journalism
and politics and Fame and society and
what happens when we disassociate
ourselves from all the things that made
us human are we more human or less human
what will we be tomorrow that we're not
today for bonus point who would play
spider Jerusalem Tim Roth Wow
current Tim Roth or Reservoir Dogs Tim
Roth current Tim Roth I think he should
be he should be older he should be like
the old man on the mountain who's got to
come back into the world and dispense
some truth when was the last time they
worked together hey hateful a part we
also kind of wanted to go Jonah Hex
because Quentin seems in love with
[ __ ] westerns yeah for reasons that
escaped me but but yeah I could [ __ ]
see that too
what would be your suggestion I was
thinking Sam Jackson as an older blade
kind of a Dark Knight
that's [ __ ] good man yeah that's
[ __ ] good I want to [ __ ] work at
the studio you're in charge oh because
we know Quentin likes vampires [ __ ] from
dusk till dawn yes samurai sword play
and all that and then I was also
thinking maybe like Madsen is the
Punisher Michael Madsen is the Punisher
you got a thing for Madsen man yeah yeah
and you're carrying that [ __ ] not
only do you win the tickets that's so
good you win the pop man give it up
pleasure oh good all right we're going
where we going next JC hey what's your
name Garcia give it up for Darcy Darcy
take us there honestly the question that
I had really piggy backs off of
homebodies question before I was
formulating this question in the car on
the way here and I wondered if y'all get
ever got a chance to adapt a film
adaptation of like a theater 101 like
play scripts like Shakespeare Oscar
Wilde like Voltaire even Chekhov what
film would it be and why I would go
Robert bolts a man for all seasons one
of my favorite [ __ ] plays in the
world it's pornography if you love
language like if language turns you on
that that play is just absolute
pornography it's also a play and later
on a wonderful movie by Fred Zinnemann
that won the Academy Award in 1969 a
study on faith which I you know I fell
in love with it when I was young
Catholic kid going to Catholic school as
an altar boy and stuff because he was
such a hero like was the scarlet not
Scarlet Letter
was the moment John Proctor a crucible
crucible was something that like you
know I was forced to read in school and
[ __ ] not like it but at the same time I
never understood like his big beef is
like I believe me my name it's
about his [ __ ] name Thomas More
struggle was always far more compelling
to me because it was about as his
conscience would have been so easy like
the whole crux is like you have to sign
this piece of paper and he's like I
can't because if I do that I will lose
everything about Who I am like he has a
great line in it about like when a
person Jo who takes an oath they hold
themselves in their hands like water and
if they open their fingers they can't
help that they won't hope to find
themselves again [ __ ] like that it's
about being true to yourself even at the
peril of your life and stuff so III love
the movie that Fred Zinnemann may has
got an amazing cast Paul Scofield won an
Academy Award for playing Thomas More
Robert Shaw is in it captain Quint from
Jaws plays a young Henry the eighth and
he's [ __ ] spellbinding it's like a a
cameo at best it's about a 15-minute
scene but he steals the whole [ __ ]
movie and really gives you the
impression of like what royalty behaves
like especially this young guy most of
the Henry the eighth's we think about
he's fat he's had a bunch of beheaded
wives and he's eating food and [ __ ] this
was the young buck like Henry the eighth
and [ __ ] who was just taking over the
throne it's fascinating wonderful
[ __ ] story
it could easily be updated today I'm not
updated like we have changed it you
could just do a current version of it
one of the last versions I think they
did was oddly enough Charlton Heston
wanted to do it and played the role of
Thomas More on TV but it's a it's a
piece that probably in the political
climate today works just as well as it
did when it was made what about you uh I
am NOT a theater kid I was despite
growing up in New York despite growing
up a stone's throw from [ __ ] Broadway
was never my thing it was what my
grandmother took me when I needed
culture what did she take you to she
took me to see the tap dance kid with
Alphonse over we are on to reduce all
that [ __ ] like I remember seeing the
commercial for that when I was going on
because I grew up in Jersey and so you'd
see the New York feed all the time like
the tap dance kid and I'm like that's
the kid went on to be on Silver Spoons
he was Rick's buddy
he was anyone onto another show I forget
what it was
I don't know and when he wasn't the most
famous person on that show by the end of
it yeah yeah that's right good point
that's where it's going in he was the
star of the show going out not so much I
can't do his dance the crowd but I I
think so crazy that the Carlton was
invented by the tap dance kid who was
also the kid in the Pepsi commercial
right the dance with Michael Jackson
that fact he's like the Forrest Gump of
this [ __ ] man like oh he's been
everywhere at every important moment in
pop culture there he is Carlton Annette
and [ __ ] yeah tap dance Keith dance kid
was the first thing I ever saw on
Broadway but I think and if I can't do
Hamilton because nobody Butlins you do
Hamilton a fellow I think I think of all
of Shakespeare's things it's the one
that appeals to me the most I think it
is right now at this very moment the
most trenchant you know an entire play
about identity and cleaving to that and
and I'm realizing who you are and
assumptions made about you and Prejudice
and all that like I think there's
there's a way but you don't have to
update very much at all and it's been
updated before like I actually kind of
like oh did you ever see oh yes good i
school yeah but I think I think there's
there's a way to either do it [ __ ]
period just do it for real or find any
setting for it find any milieu for it
but there's always going to be the I am
the one in the room story because I've
been the one in the room and so I know
kind of what that feels like
so yeah if you ever choose to produce
that I would love to see it do you have
money you know what you'll need money
cuz you're about to see a movie for
[ __ ] free you are give it up for our
thank you doctor he goes that's my baby
love you as well
what's your name captain hi my name is
Corey Corey everyone give it up for
Corey man excellent jacket thank you I
figured if I was coming to see you I had
to wear shorts you dressed appropriately
yes look at you you know I came all the
way from Jersey where what part of James
Bergen County door the bus yeah I'm like
great rabbi Paramus mall rats was
actually the first thing I was
introduced to from you and that turned
me into clerks and everything else
thank you you sir the last year has been
kind of rough and back in December when
last Jedi came out you two I started
getting into your podcast which got me
into all the SModcast podcast
I just finished Jay and Bob now I'm on
SModcast proper oh but you two guys were
such a huge inspiration that when I said
I came out I was like you know I'm gonna
do a movie review put it on YouTube and
I started doing YouTube reviews and Mark
your critical eye has totally changed
the way I look at movies I'm very much
like you I see a movie I come out I'm
like that was [ __ ] awesome yeah and
then I listen to what Mark has to say
when you talk about movies and now the
way I look at movies I look at them
through your eyes and I can see
different things totally changed the way
I appreciate not just being critical on
a movie but even the way I look at
things and you've just been an
inspiration from day one and I was
actually at your Q&A back in Atlantic
Highlands before oh yeah
the Film Fest yeah and I was hoping to
get up and ask a question didn't get a
chance to and I just personally want to
say thank you and like it's easy to love
your idols and just appreciate them for
all they do but you guys are like really
good human beings thank you
you saved two two lives just by talking
right with Jason and Brian Johnson now
you know and Mark everything you do I
mean you guys are just really good
people and I respect for these guys do
ya so it's a big deal for me especially
coming all the way to Jersey this whole
vacation has just been kind of like I'd
went from San Fran and drove the PCH for
the first time Oh [ __ ] she's amazing
it's been a great vacation now I'm
sitting here talking to you guys and I'm
like I'm about to melt but question why
this is what life is always like in
California move on out yeah literally
this I've come here now is the third
summer in a row and every time I'm like
a little bit closer to moving out it's
probably gonna happen but question wise
so big Comic Book Guy
and last year I thought white night was
one of the best books to come out the
concept of flipping Batman and Joker is
fascinating and for the question I for
you too is if you take any superhero and
their counterpart right like for me I'll
take the layup like Darkseid and
Superman I think it'd be really
interesting to flip that what two
characters super hero and villain would
you like to see flipped where the bad
guy is the good guy and the hero all of
a sudden is kind of villainized a lot of
superheroes are right on the edge where
if they cross that line they could
become villains and vice-versa
that was that's good question man the we
were talking about forget where but I
said something about like like I think
it was on fat man Batman somebody asked
a question I was like well I'd be cool
to see like a where hooks the good guy
and beautif ants bad guy and then
somebody was like they did that on once
which is show that I don't follow so
apparently they did that I'm gonna let
you lead because I'm trying to think of
one all right I got one do you I do Reed
Richards and Doctor Doom oh that's
[ __ ] good I'll be honest I think I
think they are both two sides of the
same coin but for a bad twist of fate
and there's a world in which Victor Von
Doom could absolutely be the leader of
the feminist therefore could absolutely
be the man of destiny he always thought
he was and Reed Richards having
everything taken from him by that man of
Destiny could go [ __ ] bad and he's
kind of a dick anyway any sign of a
[ __ ] I think there's there's there's
a way you could spin that that still
feels true to
characters are without and not betraying
that but still have a really fun that
that's that thing I think is so cool
about the best heroes and villains as
you can flip-flop them and it can work
both ways
it's the magneto Professor X thing it's
like these are two people bonded by so
much who shares so many things but for
perspective I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm not
gonna whack it out of the park but I'm
definitely gonna get on base and then
I'm gonna steal second forts yeah I
don't know where that came something
loose I know it's so strange I'm talking
big touchdown
I think score he shoots he scores
I think in listening to his answer I and
I mean it's t it kind of jumps off yours
a little bit less Superman and Darkseid
for me more Superman Lex Luthor like you
could do a great story where Lex Luthor
has to save metropolis from [ __ ]
Superman that's how he sees it like Lex
Luthor doesn't see himself as like a
criminal [ __ ] mastermind and [ __ ]
unless he's you know [ __ ] Gene
Hackman the greatest criminal mind never
existed but I think he sees himself as
like I cared about this city long before
this [ __ ] alien ship he's just
defeated by his own hatred by his racism
essentially at the end of it and stuff
so he sees himself as somebody who's
gonna save metropolis or the world from
[ __ ] Superman you could do a version
of that story where he's not wrong where
Superman like you know the red Sun
version of Superman where he's [ __ ]
not here for America and stuff like that
that's kind of compelling and they've
done versions of it right like there's
always a Lex Luthor that comes from
another dimension where they're like
you're [ __ ] dead Luthor and he's have
hold on I'm the good Luthor and [ __ ]
which is a very Rick and Morty move man
like no no I'm the one that wears the
fishin hat you know didn't there was a
miniseries called Luthor wasn't there DC
did why man I remember they did like a
one shot called Luthor that told the
story about like him kill one's parents
and stuff like that but I don't know if
they did they must have done an elf
world's version where he's a good guy
and they did like man for all seasons
was also about Luthor
yeah but not being the good guy what I
was the one issue where it's all three
his perspective yes and there's one the
slowest this perspective ones this
Jimmy's perspective and so the look that
the Luthor issue was very much the I
could save the city like I'm the one I'm
I can affect infrastructure I can I can
make change I can make real change I'm
social level except for that [ __ ] guy
right let's imagine you could do
something where you know it's you'd have
to you don't have to you do whatever you
want but I would imagine it'd be easier
to tell an origin story so Superman or
the ubermensch arrives in Metropolis and
he's not there to help god bless you and
Justice League Superman essentially and
yes and so that activates Luthor to
saved the city and you know [ __ ]
eventually he gets to the point where he
has to build a suit in which to face
this guy so you get him in the [ __ ]
combat suit and [ __ ] like that
yeah you could do it you could do a lock
on a dais you can do it where where
Luthor is Salieri and Superman is Mozart
yeah listen I I [ __ ] got really great
I am I've got the ear of the king I
kiddin I can make all these changes I
can I can help shift the way everybody
listens to music in Vienna
except for that [ __ ] kid yeah I like
that I like your version of Superman and
Lex Luthor that is a great question and
it got a great answer you get [ __ ]
tickets give it up for a man alright man
to says dick is left in one pop how's it
going how are you what's your name my
name is Fabian Fabio everyone give it up
for Fabio did I say enough dose enough
baby n yeah that one oh so is Fabian
like the singer yeah baby oh no one
romário Fabian right Amin I just got a
couple of gifts for you oh you got I got
pens literally pens right like they pens
or anything like
[ __ ] my old man actually made him bread
sitting in the booth right there he you
literally made that pen you made this
pen [ __ ] beautiful man I'm not just
saying that because he just sends me
like this is a legit gorgeous pen what
does something like this cost so when I
put it up on a B I know what to charge
how much does it normally cost 75 bucks
for this pen oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] keeping
it I would hope so
absolutely beautiful look at you making
something we talked about making [ __ ]
all time we make pretend you literally
made a thing and put it into the world
well done give it up for his pen ladies
a joke thank you so that that goes into
my story time it's gonna get a little
dark really quickly uh my dad actually
is a survivor of cancer well done man
give it up for me survive you know and
that leads into my question if you guys
had to permanently kill off a superhero
yeah dead not like this Wolverine crap
where he comes back with a space stone
and whatnot but literally just gone for
good
who would you kill and who would you
have speak at their eulogy Oh what
villain what no what's super villain
would you have speak at their eulogy
you know like saber-toothed Wolverine
Doctor Doom you know Reed Richards your
directing career in that tusks movie
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if this is what you raised and mark now
marker cool we're good
it's the red wedding of questions came
out of nowhere I got stabbed in the dick
enjoy the Pens the rains of Western
mirrors let me think
ma'am you want to go first yah go first
I would kill daredevil the devil you say
why because I I think you want to kill I
mean I almost went spider-man but that's
a little too easy but I think you want
to kill somebody he's human I think you
want it to be about the fragility of
life you want it to be about he was the
best of us because he had the most to
lose by being one of us and then you
have kingpin speak at his [ __ ]
funeral and then you have him talk about
you know and of course unwelcome there
because he's [ __ ] kingpin it's like
eight seats but talk about oh that's why
he's unwelcome at the funeral then like
he's a little heavy there's not enough
room here but but I think it's it's it's
about the the worthiness of the
adversary and the fact that that his
life they have been they defined each
other over time and he would not have
been able to scale the heights that he
scale to do the evil that he's done had
there not been somebody to challenge him
in a return and without one you don't
get the other and so thank you for being
a [ __ ] [ __ ] on my side you're all
dead goodbye can I give you mine don't
wait cuz then I'll make fun of your [ __ ]
fair enough fair enough
Nightcrawler I would kill off okay and
have mystique speak at the eulogy just
blue because that's his son that's why
that's his mom in the current continuity
yeah
mystique is nightcrawlers mother yeah
when did they do that with the zeizel
with what Azazel yeah the the other one
that goes poof I wrote that
comical balls you uh I wrote a
Nightcrawler origins comic for Marvel
and basically was Dumbo we did the Dumbo
story as but nightcrawlers Dumbo right
and this weird [ __ ] free kid born in
a circus and his mom you know tries to
take care of him but can't and [ __ ]
fire in the circus and they go off on
their way in the wild but yes I mean
that was that was a continuity that was
presented to us where's mystique was his
mom what year was it this would have
been 2010 2011 it feels like a recent
thing that was not angel they just angel
yeah that's a new earth that's good let
me see what would I do
mmm and the idea is all right who do you
kill for good rest in peace
never to come back gone alright [ __ ]
I'm gonna do it everyone's gonna hate it
but here comes Batman and who speaks as
funeral is Ra's al Ghul I know everyone
thought I'd go Joker that's ridiculous
he's crazy Ra's al Ghul could speak to
like he respected him today and I'm not
talking movie Ra's al Ghul I'm talking
about the one from the comics the one
that refers to him as the detective and
stuff the one who's like only you are
good enough for my daughter detective
that that that would be a cool scene I
don't know if it's worth killing off
Batman but we have had a bunch of Batman
stories so like at the end of the day
it's not like you can never read them
again it's just there would be no new
ones now that means there'd be no new
ones but you could tell old ones
that's essentially what they do all the
time is tell old stories usually so you
can kill them off and be like it won't
doesn't go forward like in the universe
like it but you can always go back and
tell old stories did Marvel do that
wasn't that something like initiative
they had called the end where it was
like the final story of yeah yeah it's
okay we're gonna get there I love final
stories this is always a fun gimmick
whenever they do that in the books and
[ __ ] like old man Logan and stuff like
that which eventually led to us seeing
that movie but one of my favorites and
I've talked about a minute
it's not just on the show but everywhere
is rock of ages' agile a story that
Grant Morrison wrote and Howard Porter
drew they did like the last DC story
with like the universe blowing up at the
end and then like B to do it to beat
Darkseid and [ __ ] and then Orion like
sets off a [ __ ] bomb that's gonna
destroy the entire [ __ ] universe and
so death the black racer shows up and
death the black racers represented is
Jack Kirby character from the new gods
the universe the fourth world he's a guy
on skis like he's a little man on skis
whereas a black outfit has a cape and
stuff and that's their representation of
death and it has one of my favorite
lines in a comic book ever [ __ ]
written because the whole episode the
whole issue is narrated by death the
black racer because it's all about the
end of the [ __ ] universe and how
they're all and all these storylines are
coming together they're about to finally
beat [ __ ] Darkseid and [ __ ]
it's amazing [ __ ] story so black
racer keeps encountering all the
characters and he's the narrating voice
and they save it till the end they don't
show you in the first few pages cuz if
you saw it was a little man on skis
you'd be like [ __ ] this
but it's so well written that when they
reveal the black racer you don't even
giggle you're like this [ __ ]
beautiful it absolutely makes sense so
he encounters it's not even like he he
has a moment with Batman which is
[ __ ] amazing stuff but my favorite
moment is he encounters Ray Palmer the
atom and he says the voice-over is this
one sees me and like a good scientist
asks me a question I say yes and that
captured my imagination and still does
to this day cuz I don't know what the
question is I think it's and I asked
grant I was like did he ask him are you
death and grant goes [ __ ] remember
those years ago and [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] book and that told the story of
the end of the DC Universe oh this
[ __ ] unparalleled writing if you've
got a chance get your hands on Rock of
Ages
did you answer I did we all answer this
great question you win [ __ ] tickets
give it up our man
thank you for the pen all right we got
one ticket left and one pop man JC
picked kal [ __ ] what do you got what's
your name my friend my name is Kyle has
going keV I won't give it up for Kyle
[Applause]
first I just wanted to say when clerks
came out in 93 I was working in a
convenience store so you're kind of my
patron saint was that the line that
defined me was uh was what do you mean
there's no why's you saying I got a
drink this coffee hot yeah she's crazy
when kids what like my kid finally saw
clerks for the first time on my birthday
we had a mini Film Festival in New
Jersey carriers was there
vulgar thon and so the kid came out and
I was like look why don't you be a guest
watch clerks because she's never seen it
and then we'll talk about it afterwards
and stuff and so one of the things she
said to me later on the day was like I
don't understand why everyone made a big
deal about drinking coffee with ice and
I was like oh because you grew up in a
world where there's a coffee store
everywhere and they serve iced coffee
but where I grew up the notion of
putting ice and coffee was like
ridiculous she was like how old is this
movie yeah
it's in black and white I know I know a
couple of younger kids who won't watch
it simply because it's in black and
white yeah well my my question was if
there was any origin or ending of a
particular character across any medium
really that you feel you could do like
either better or just a slightly Wilder
twist what would it be
I'm not gonna this ain't to [ __ ] on
anybody else's work this is just what I
would do I would give Luke Skywalker or
more heroic death that's and I'm not
saying that I didn't I like that movie I
like last Jedi a lot I'm on record I
like what Ryan did instead but you know
there was a moment when I was watching
that movie where I was [ __ ]
breathless because I was like oh my god
they threaded the [ __ ] needle at
point he [ __ ] says am I gonna do
stand in front of the Empire face him
down with a laser sword and then he
[ __ ] dot did it and I was like oh god
we're gonna watch him beat all these
[ __ ] with a laser sword and [ __ ] even
though I normally call it a lightsaber
whatever like I [ __ ] can't wait and
then I remember that that's that's the
Marvel Comics movie fan and me expecting
him to be a superhero but Jedi's didn't
age into superheroes like we knew that
from the first [ __ ] movie Ben Kenobi
wasn't like shooting Frank he was an old
man and [ __ ] who eventually gets killed
and like they weren't superheroes they
were just people who aged out and [ __ ]
they were real good with their magic
powers but like like any human being
they eventually frail and Gotha frail
and break so I understand what Ryan did
and I think it makes sense and this is
in keeping with how they've always
treated old Jedi's in that universe but
there was a part of me that just wanted
to see him [ __ ] like as kylo Ren was
like fire every gun we have on that man
and just to watch him as ridiculous as
it would have been like to do what Yoda
did when he fought Count Dooku's just
like without breaking a [ __ ] sweat
like oh my god I would have jerked off
in the theater man like oh I knew it the
same way like we saw rogue one and
they're like here's Darth Vader like if
we could have had that moment where
they're like here's the master Jedi but
that's not how that narrative was ever
really built so it honestly probably
would have went against character and
went against brand to give me something
that I wanted and I can get in any
number of other movies right a superhero
moment but in a world where this is
happening we're the like hey man [ __ ]
you're gonna you're gonna drop dead soon
so we'll let you do whatever the [ __ ]
you want with any character and [ __ ] and
like I'd be hard-pressed to think of
somebody that I would like to play with
more than [ __ ] Luke Skywalker and and
only by virtue of the fact that he's
gone now we lost him that's it I mean
he'll be back as a ghost they always are
but like but like he's his character is
now [ __ ] past and stuff so that's
that's the one I might grab what about
you
so characters the death that I
could take back in refashion or or
origin if you think there's a different
twist you could put on another character
I'm gonna go death and I'm gonna go mr.
Anderson oh I I think you could absolute
do a [ __ ] better death than me Oh God
in the end of those four just he's got
all the power just [ __ ] goes back in
time it just lives in the first movie
and we just only ever get the first
movie yeah just wipes the other two from
existence because he's [ __ ] me oh
yeah I felt the same way about Keanu and
devil's advocate I felt that I felt they
should have ended it right when he shot
himself yeah yeah I agree with that that
would have been a [ __ ] badass ending
to a movie and [ __ ] but to be fair I'm
the guy that made tusks and that movie
should have been did maybe in the first
twenty minutes but they were [ __ ] guy
Lapointe raises the gun and he's gonna
shoot the [ __ ] Moors like universally
that's what people tell me the like why
didn't you end the movie there they're
like you put him in a [ __ ] petting
zoo at the end and [ __ ] and I'm always
like well that's what we said on the
podcast that was about the yeah spoilers
if you haven't seen tusk yet you're
never [ __ ] watching this [ __ ] why are
you here but but I was honoring the
podcast but I do when I look at the
movie I understand when people say that
I'm like oh that would have been a
better ending and the movie probably
would have done better and [ __ ] but like
then the movie goes on for another five
minutes with some really ridiculous [ __ ]
so yeah maybe I might redo the ending of
my own movie but I like yours man that's
[ __ ] awesome cuz it's true
he went out so [ __ ] soft like if for
a guy who is like modern-day Jesus all
of a sudden he just [ __ ] died you
know cuz mr. snow kind of meeting with
some yeah well I'll give you Superman
then having to be [ __ ] Superman yeah
I like that that's a great question man
you win tickets give it up for my is
Java
[Applause]
goddamn pleasure we still have a pop
yeah so I mean I feel we can hold it
till next week or we could try to go for
broke who wants lose feeling strong with
a great [ __ ] question jump on up are
you leading with I don't have a great
question uh what's your name
everyone give it up for D all right D
that pop is on the line man here we go I
don't want the pop I know that's Pappas
for me but I was wondering could you
autograph my leg so I can get a tattooed
yeah I got a I got a sharpie I mean you
can't get it up on the bark and whip it
up just wait over there on the way out
I'll tag it for you you know you don't
have to we don't have to do right now
that just go right by the end of the bar
and then as we get out of tag that's
awesome thank you there's a no problem
you're going in the wrong direction go
the other way you grabbing your [ __ ] you
thought people would take your [ __ ] not
this crowd you're from Texas what part
Medford Texas I think I've been there
I've actually bleep I've been there I'm
right on here I'll tag it in a minute
man
look Clark what do you have to ask us
hey what's going on what's your night in
Dan and we'll give it up for Dan thank
you you actually followed me on Twitter
once we've met before we met on the set
a cop out in Bay Ridge where your
trailer was right in front of my
brother's house you brought me over to
Marc Platt because we're talking about
Scott Pilgrim and how I was like I don't
want to bias Scott Pilgrim sure I want
to buy this shirt Scott Pilgrim wears
and you were like you have to tell this
to mark nice to see Mike I'm not set to
for a day you don't remember me I I was
a favorite also you didn't introduce me
all I remember is Tracy Morgan making a
whole bunch of dick jokes as soon as he
came out of his trailer which whatever
yes you had to be there my my trailer
was the trailer that whenever the door
opened it was like a lot of smoke went
out there yeah we explained to a bunch
of old ladies in the neighborhood like
what was going on here and the like yeah
he you know makes movies you know the 37
takes being on that set and you got a
[ __ ] me Tracy Tracy's amazing so I
met Tracy and he launched into a one-man
rendition of Planet of the Apes
we're like he knew all the [ __ ] lines
and then they made our topic yes so cool
[ __ ] gotta go onstage with that my
favorite memory of Tracy on cop-out and
there are many but this happened on
[ __ ] day one was right before we shot
our very first [ __ ] scene and it was
like the first day and whatnot this is
like me and Bruce were still friendly so
it was right at the beginning and Tracy
he goes hey keV last night I watched
Frankenstein and I was like oh right on
man which one the one with like DeNiro
no he's like nah man the old one with
Frankenstein you know what he goes you
know what the problem is I said what he
goes they treat Fritz like a [ __ ] and I
had to think like who the [ __ ] is Fritz
and I guess it's it's dr. Frankenstein's
like like assistant or something like
that like the guy he Gore we think of
his Igor but he's calling him fritz and
so he does like 10 minutes on how
[ __ ] it's not right to treat fritz
that way it was funny I was having a
good time and then we went to shoot a
scene and you know in the beginning
first take both actors I assumed would
be doing the same thing which was we had
a script that was on the blacklist like
one of the most liked unproduced scripts
in town people really dug the script so
I assumed like you know we'd be shooting
the script Tracy is a bit of an ADD
liver but I'd had a conversation with
Tracy in advance where I'm like wheat
this scripts good and the writers are on
set so like don't go crazy with
ad-libbing like I had him in Jay and
Silent Bob strike back and [ __ ] he
brings like
things to a production he was the one
that named the characters that can I
call my character pumpkin Escobar and I
was like yes because that's a free joke
thank you
so I said before this as I guess our
first day like just let's stick to the
script and stuff he's a go cake app so
we go to do our first [ __ ] take and
Bruce Willis is like not doing the
script he starts ad living and [ __ ] he's
literally sitting there just going
looking out the window and he's gone
like that Connie Chung over there
I think that's Connie Chung's that maury
povich he's naming everybody from the
80s as he looks out the window that was
his ad libbing and [ __ ] like that and so
at the end of that take like Tracy
looked at me from where he was sitting
and like looked at me as if like he's
[ __ ] making up dialogue so I just
went like this and I said like go ahead
so the next [ __ ] take I'm like action
and Bruce was looking out the window and
he's going who's that is that Connie
Chung out there I think I see Connie
Chung working walking away and Tracy all
of a sudden goes Jimmy cuz that's Bruce
Lee's character it was Jimmy man you
know what I did last night
I watched Frankenstein and so sit behind
the monitor I'm like no way and he
literally did the same [ __ ] bit that
he had just done for me and it was
wonderful man cuz I was a god it's
[ __ ] great and [ __ ] but like the
other guy
his expression dropped because his thing
of like let's ad-lib it's like hey man I
think I see Maury Povich out there I
think I see Connie Chung Tracy just
created a whole different scene and then
Bruce was like where are we what the
Frankenstein what the [ __ ] so he was he
was wonderful man he came loaded for
[ __ ] bear so I don't I don't I I
imagine what you say is absolutely
[ __ ] true that sounds like Tracy the
transannular [ __ ] moments that movie
is an image I took a picture of Tracy
Morgan we're at the end of the night we
were doing a wet down on the street it
was late at night so car was pulling up
so you have to wet the street town sore
reflects and stuff and
he saw the dude doing the wet down like
the wet down truck came in a fascinating
to me goes all they do is make things
wet that's my job and so uh so he goes
give can I work the hose and I was like
him man go ahead if you want it I was
like a kid Tracy work the hose and
they're like I guess Tracy goes over and
gets the hose and he had a cigarette
dangling from his lips and he's [ __ ]
just holding the hose at dick level and
spraying down the street and yeah and
and the cigarette is like just dangling
perfectly like off this and he goes keV
take a picture and so I took a picture
he goes no no I do a video and so I got
this ten second video of him like
wetting the street down smoking a
cigarette and he looks at me and [ __ ]
and at the end you go send that to me
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright anyway here we go man chance to
win a pop yes so what is the biggest
unanswered question and or plot hole
that still just get such kind of like
what did the black writer ask her you
know what they asked like writer write
what is that one that one thing that
you're just like what you tell me just
fix it and if it's a plot hole how would
you have filled it in I I mean there's
gonna be low-hanging fruit because just
because it's come up a few times but the
the the who has raised parents like you
know is something I would like to see
solved I wish it have been solved in the
first movie that's a real JJ moved to be
like hey man you don't know who her
parents are I'm not gonna tell you that
any [ __ ] runs away and [ __ ] so I
that's something that I would like
solved [ __ ] fast like it used to be
on Game of Thrones it was like oh man is
[ __ ] Jon Snow and and [ __ ] Khaleesi
ever gonna meet and then they [ __ ]
did it so for me it feels like the REA
parentage thing cuz you know I I was
betting hard cold hard money on the fact
that she was related to obi-wan Kenobi
and then suddenly in last Jedi they were
like man she's just used as
her parents were junkies or something
like that [ __ ] or junk traders or
whatever the [ __ ] piece is better yeah
right way better version of Star Wars
we're [ __ ] Ray's parents who like hey
man you got a fix so as the one I'd go
for you suck your dick for droid money
droid money portion I know this is sort
of been answered before if you if you
like boost the [ __ ] audio and you
grind it out like a FBI [ __ ]
surveillance expert but I do kind of
want to know what Bill Murray whispers
to Scarlett Johansson I remember seeing
the movie first time I watch that oh
that's classy and then the next time I
watched it was like and say yeah come on
if I can put it on the Internet somebody
say something [ __ ] I think somebody did
[ __ ] like boost the audio and adjust
the levels and you can kind of make out
what he whispers but not really but I
just I really want to [ __ ] know
Sophie it like tell me what the [ __ ] he
says to her it would be amazing if he
was like thinner that question warranted
a wonderful answer but I don't think
it's pop worthy give it up for him that
was great though an excellent job I go
for it again one more try one more you
think you can win this pop yes I do
can a man confidence what's your name
captain my name is John I'm from Trenton
New Jersey yeah well give it up a job
from Trenton man balls of steel John
what do you got Trenton makes the world
takes absolutely pork roll yes anyway
I live in Arizona now okay I'm from East
Coast's and everything and my friend
from Australia where we work for fender
of musical instruments
and I come bearing gifts oh [ __ ] free
swag absolutely well then you definitely
win the pop is one of them as awesome is
one of them at guitar yeah it looks like
a good tie I listened to the to the
podcast on my commute and I've seen this
part of the show often to where the
exact same thing that you say to
everyone is the question should be made
to you and mark equally in order to
actually get it get the prize right so I
always thought as I was driving what
would I ask if I ever made my way here
and luckily I got the opportunity to
come visit our Hollywood office and you
guys were here so hey man so did you
close in a circle so yeah don't Excel
them in life does anybody get to go I
had a dream and it's about to come true
very much yeah exactly so the question
that I came up with months ago was
basically this both of you are
established and creative writers for
your entire career but the way you
eloquently tell a story especially
during the podcast every week is that
something that developed along with your
writing career or have you guys always
been good speakers I mean we think of
you as great writers directors creative
talent for Hollywood but where does the
the oratory come from first off if you
keep calling us great writers you're
gonna win three pops I cannot speak for
mark mark will speak for himself but for
me the writing thing or the or the
oratory thing the oral if you will that
came out of being pushed in front of the
movie to talk about it like whenever you
make a movie you go to a film festival
when it's done to like go out there and
answer questions about it and stuff so I
would go out and instead of answering
questions seriously like an auteur like
you know I pretty point-and-shoot kind
of movie there wasn't much I could
relate about like how we made it other
than like we shot it and black and white
and we shot it in the store
drivers I being a big fan of stand-up
comedy and George Carlin particularly I
was like if they're gonna put a mic in
my hands then I'm just I'm not gonna try
to be informative I'm gonna try to make
them laugh like I'm gonna try to make it
fun and [ __ ] like that so I'm not gonna
you like talk about the minutiae or the
vision or anything like that I'm gonna
tell them how we got the cat to [ __ ] on
cue or something like that like a
charming making up story so that that's
where I started like you know developing
the the oratory like the idea of like
getting up and telling a story and stuff
and when you're in front of people and
you have to do it again and again you
just don't want to sound like an idiot
you want to sound smooth and stuff so
practice kind of makes perfect I think
it absolutely helps that I was a writer
first I've got a fairly decent
vocabulary from which to pull [ __ ] from
and whatnot you can't tell when I say to
pull [ __ ] from but I do have a pretty
decent vocabulary now I'm sounding like
Trump I got all the best words but I do
have a fairly decent vocabulary I think
that does kind of help but I mine was a
conscious effort also podcasting first
like I've been doing it for 11 years
that will make you but you know 10,000
hours right let make you better at
anything so like I I've been doing Q&A
since 1994 and then the podcasts since
2007 so all of that helps me jump up in
front of a crowd like my friend Malcolm
Ingram is shooting a documentary about
me now and they interviewed my wife
today and my wife was like I saw her
afterwards I was like how to go and she
was like I was so nervous I was like
you're talking about like the one
subject that like you know better than
anybody in this world me like [ __ ]
why are you nervous and [ __ ] and she's
like because I'm not like you I don't
get up every day and tell everyone
everything that's on my [ __ ] mind
like you know she's like I don't do as
much public speaking abuse as you so it
was really [ __ ] weird she's gone but
it was comfortable at a certain point
because I was talking about you and I
was a god that's kind of sweet so she
pointed out like that like you do that a
lot and I think that's why I got better
at it because it just happens again and
again you uh
nobody had ever put me in front of a
movie to talk to people about things
yeah a little while if you don't mind
mark actually you're the one who in in
my mind as listening really kind of
stands out more in terms nothing against
Kevin but when it comes to first it was
the guy about tusk now you six months
after the heart attack people like [ __ ]
him the truth is back the honeymoon is
over yeah you got better old man now
here's a big dick of truth in your face
but you're right mark is very own mark
no I mean it's it's I came up in
journalism and and it was always a
matter of sitting on a table with people
who were smarter than I was who had more
experience than I did who had been doing
it longer than I ever did and having to
make them take my ideas seriously and
you know I was 25 years old when I went
to Entertainment Weekly and the dude who
was running it was like a People
magazine editor for 30 years like he's
[ __ ] old gray air salt pepper like he
was what you imagined in your head
he's like Jay jonah Jameson's number two
you know and so so to find ways to get
people to take me seriously to be able
to present ideas to that room which was
filled with the smartest people I've
ever met
it forced me to hone what I was going to
say and be able to deliver it in a
concise way so a not to take up a lot of
air and B to make sure that I was
understood and to the point where like
sometimes I got shot down that's fine
but I never felt like an [ __ ] for
standing up and saying something and so
20 years of having to do that of having
to and as you do it more and she came
experience and you rise up the ranks and
you get to speak with real honesty and
and and be able just like I'm not really
sure that if this [ __ ] makes sense
but what if that went a long way and
then when we started podcasting it I had
never spoken at length like this before
and then when it was hey man you want to
do it in front of a live crowd like sure
I guess like I had never harbored any
like I want to be on a stage despite
having been the lead singer of a really
shitty rock band in high school
so yeah what really what kind of ban new
covers or original mostly covers what
you covered
we covered we covered bands that had
really shitty lead singers so like the
Red Hot Chili Peppers recovered a bit of
we covered we covered Jimi Hendrix a
couple of times because again like Jimi
Hendrix did not have an amazing [ __ ]
voice he had an okay voice everything
else was glorious and like tikides
I like quite a bit not [ __ ] David Lee
Roth right so he's not because that was
my fantasy but so yeah they're like I'd
been on a stage before I'd I performed
in front of people speaking was way less
emotionally sort of scarring and singing
in front of people because but when we
started doing it it was being able to do
it in your house first and like just
getting up to speed and and Kev secret
power is being able to talk and he's a
rock on tour that way and it's it's
glorious to watch when you're like just
next to him chiming in every now and
again and then getting the confidence to
try and be more a part of it and then
being able to me it's all about
confidence it's all about repetition
it's all about doing it over and over
again and now it being able to do it and
not think about it like my dad's English
is a second language his first language
is French and and he would always say
like I knew that I was I knew that I had
English when I was able to think in
English because for the longest time he
was translating his head before I was
talking instead when I could think in
English then I felt like I had it then I
felt fluent and being able to think in
in podcast being able to just get it and
feel it and trust it you know then that
that is the gift of it and it only comes
to repetition and confidence and it's
funny like I when I was I was pitching a
TV show the beginning of the year and
and and and the managers and agents they
wanted me to practice the pitch right go
home [ __ ] memorized then we'll come
to the office and we'll do it and take
notes and whatever and I'm like listen
guys I I get it I understand that
is what you want you want to know what
it is but there's parts of this that I
know the show better than anybody and I
trust that when I get in there I'll be
able to tell this story right because
I've been telling stories now on a stage
or in front of a camera for the last
like five or six years and I'm not gonna
say that I'm a [ __ ] improv Wiz I'm
not gonna say that I'm like some kind of
master orator but if I know what I'm
talking about then I trust that the
words will come and I think that that
the last five years have been sort of
proof at least for me that I can I can
fall back and feel comfortable knowing
that I didn't know how I was gonna start
this anecdote but I'll find a way to end
it mmm you know very good thank you also
like you you got thrown into the deep
end of the pool pretty quickly whereas
like Mark stand next to me and say a lot
of things and and you've you know
there's a I don't I am NOT comparing
myself to the great one in this analogy
but one of the things I always loved
about reading about Wayne Gretzky as a
player in hockey was that everyone who
played with them or on his line and
stuff they were like all you have to do
is hold up your end of the bargain and
he'll take you anywhere
like you'll he'll you'll score but you
just have to you just have to do your
[ __ ] job and stuff and if you're
there magic happens and stuff and it's
it's that's kind of like what the vibe
is here except we're both Gretzky like
sometimes you're like oh what are we
though yes you're wearing the [ __ ]
hockey jersey that's true I dress the
part tonight like you had some really
legit like funny [ __ ] like even to the
point where you're like oh did I
workshop that like like that was funny
stuff you I
number one it never occurred to me that
hasn't been five years the first time we
did a podcast together yeah was July of
2011 and that was like one of the
earliest like when you came over and
you're just a guest on the show I was a
guest with you and Jen it was it was
plus one per diem oh that's right yeah
yeah and that was the first time I'd
ever done a [ __ ] podcast and then
like just come and do more more is fun
let's keep
more is it [ __ ] up how like now you
have this whole other skill set that you
didn't have and never and didn't look
for you weren't like I'd be such a
better person if I could just podcast
classes for this yeah but like it it's
weird how something that wasn't a part
of your life like [ __ ] five years ago
is now such a big part it's a staple in
my life it's a pillar in my life and and
and in there is things that have
happened in my life and rooms that I've
been in and situations that I've been
able to navigate because I've done this
podcast some doors have opened because
they wouldn't have ordinarily I feel
more comfortable in a room pitching your
[ __ ] TV shows or isn't if I can talk
to 8,000 people on a stage in Detroit
then you know and I can pretty much deal
with you five people in this room yeah
granted you all can pay me way more than
those people in Detroit that's true but
but just the the the sense of self and
the sense of place and the sense of
feeling like you belong you know there
is there is that statement that they
always say and like when the rookie
comes to the [ __ ] sports teams like
how do I deal with the media how do we
do the press act like you've been here
before and like now I don't have to
pretend I'll have to act like I've been
here before I've been here before
and so it's it's it's changed my life in
tons of ways but it's not the answer to
the question that you asked but I also
didn't know where I was going when I
started telling the story yeah that
question gets a pop well done captain
[Applause]
pleasure man fuckin'-a that was great
dear ladies and gentlemen we don't have
any more show to give you have you had a
good time this evening we want to thank
deacon and the good folks of 40x
Jamie carriers for throwing pops out
that some [ __ ] talk was won tonight
JC for making just about the coolest bar
on the planet give it up for scum and
villainy we're and give it up give it up
for the guy without whom there is no fat
man I'm Batman
mr. mark Bernard and ladies
and that is fat man on Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I am LARPing our
tune in next time same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you